Good morning everyone. Thank you for being here
and uh happy to have you all
for this session CNS 359.
Uh, my name is Diraj Mapatra. I'm a principal
specialist solutions architect at AWS,
and with me I have
my name is AJ Park. I'm also a solutions architect here at AWS
covering, uh, generative AI.
All right, so we're gonna kick it off today.
Uh, hopefully you're excited. We're getting started here at
Reinvent.
Uh, we're gonna talk about building, deploying, and
operating agentic applications
using AWS Servius, and so
we have a lot we wanna cover, so we're gonna dive right
into it. Uh, this is just a quick overview
of our agenda, but again we're gonna dive right into
it. Just a couple of quick
assumptions here.
This is a 300 level session. There are some assumptions
around some knowledge. We won't cover a lot of the
basic definitions.
We're going to make some of those assumptions. We're also
going to start with some principles again as architects
with your architect hat on here. We're going to want to
talk about some of those principles and then we're going to apply
some of the pragmatic deployment
thinking here.
OK, so the first thing that we wanna
think through is as we think about designing
single agent systems we're gonna then transition
into multi-agent systems,
but. Before we do that, why don't we
start with a customer example, and we're
going to use this example
throughout this talk. So
you imagine we just went through Black Friday.
Your, uh, shopping, perhaps gift shopping.
Uh, I was charged twice for my order.
In fact, there should have been two items. I only received
one, and I need it actually tomorrow
for a gift, right? And so here is
they were charged twice. Here's issue number 1
that instead of being charged once, as you would
expect, the payment system perhaps
accidentally charged you twice for some reason.
Also, there you did not receive all
of the items in the order and then of course
there is this rush, uh, this impending
need to get it tomorrow because you need to actually
give this as a gift. So we're gonna think through these,
uh, problem statements throughout this, uh,
talk. So for the servius
aficionados here, we may build this with
a servalus set of servalus APIs.
This is your retail application.
Uh, again, you can imagine using domain driven design
we may have some different bounded context. You, you'll
have a number of different APIs here, right?
So maybe your order's API
is going to manage the life cycle of that,
uh, customer purchasing process.
Uh, you might use inventory management to look
in your warehouse, see what's available again. Maybe
on Black Friday you may have sold out of some of
those. So you want to be able to
notify the front end that some of these
items perhaps are not available. Again,
similarly with payments, we want to maybe do direct payments
or maybe even invoicing of your customers
and then of course the support API for maybe your
support organization
when this request comes in, we can then use
this to go and triage what perhaps went wrong.
OK, so with this
we think about this customer experience and what are we gonna
try to solve for, right? These are some
of the challenges that we're thinking through is as a
customer support agent,
maybe uh I have to respond to these and I have to
look in multiple disparate systems. Maybe there's
a payments portal internally.
Maybe there's something around inventory management.
You can imagine trying to build a dashboard or
some type of support system
that allows me to see all of these disparate
sources of information
all in one place.
Furthermore, of course you want a good customer
experience, so we don't want the customer to be sitting
and waiting for a long period of time.
So we want to be able to address this customer issue
as quickly as possible and also
you want to make sure that your support
personnel that they get quick guidance as
well so that you don't have your customer waiting
for a long period of time
before they get feedback of, hey, what's the
next potential resolution.
So can we do better? Can we do better?
Now you're thinking,
uh, I could probably do this just
by having better, you know, unit test
integration tests within my application itself,
but even we were just talking with some
folks in the in the front here
that there are ways to perhaps get
insight into data quicker
using perhaps an LLM. So
in this scenario, oops,
in this scenario, perhaps you use you integrate
an LLM. We're going to invoke a model
provide it with some amount of data.
And get some type of reasoning insight
back from this model,
right, and we're gonna talk a bunch about how do we uh
do this in a way that makes sense for our
application. So the quick naive way we
wanna think about it is we wanna provide context
to this application and to this LLM.
The first way we may think about doing that is
through this
idea of search.
Here the key thing is you're gonna have a prompt, so
maybe you have an application, you're gonna construct
a prompt through this application.
You will then perhaps go and get some
information out of a knowledge source, so this could be some type of semantic
knowledge store
and maybe this is a prior
history with this customer, maybe this
is the inventory, uh, data
warehouse, and maybe this is a uh
finance payments API.
We're gonna then go and extract that knowledge
and uh then submit an enhanced
prompt to the LOM.
The key thing that you you wanna think about here
is the fact that the application
is orchestrating the the flow
of information retrieval.
So it is the application that is gonna parse the prompt.
It is gonna go and say, OK, we need to get some
set of data, uh, out of this knowledge
source and then submit that to the LLM.
So as a developer building this type of
application, the developer needs to write
and orchestrate all of this, uh, logic.
Perhaps you may also think maybe we want to do this
a little bit more dynamically. Maybe as a developer
I don't know the actual workflow,
so perhaps there's a way we can do this where we can
have the LLM
make a determination of what the next step is without
writing imperative code.
So here you have that same prompt, the same
application. And what we're gonna now do as
part of this prompt is to submit
a list of available tools
that this LLM can then make a decision about.
The LLM can then come back and say, hey, I like,
you know, tool A and B.
I'm gonna go make a request. Can you
application go and fetch this data on my
behalf?
Now the application on behalf of the LLM
will go and fetch the data from that same knowledge source
and then we'll submit that enhanced prompt.
So the key difference here is maybe as a developer
I've actually simplified the type of
code that I'm writing or the amount of code that
I'm writing and offloading that logic
to the LLM because maybe this is something we want to do a little
bit more dynamically.
OK, so we talked a little bit about
this enhanced prompt, and you may be wondering what is that,
what exactly is that enhanced prompt?
Well, great question. Here's perhaps a JSON
document
that shows examples of, uh,
pieces of information that may be in this prompt.
So of course there, there's a system prompt
that then defines here is the persona,
the set of capabilities, and maybe
some boundary, uh, behaviors
that we have for this particular agent.
So and then of course at the bottom then is
the human prompt that was submitted, but the key thing
here is
all of this additional context at the top
is something that the application is gonna
provide in addition to the human
prompt. So these are all things that are perhaps hidden from the
user,
maybe in our case the customer support representative,
but that these are all included as part of that enhanced
prompt. And the key thing here then is
this list of tools. So we, we, uh
talked before about
there's this list of tools that we're going to submit to the
LLM. To then give it an
opportunity to make a decision about what additional
information the LLM believes it needs in order
to make a better uh choice or
a better, um, you know,
insight into the data that we wanna have.
OK, so if we then bring this back
to our traditional retail application.
We then have this application
that can go and make these tool calls.
We can then essentially wrap our serverless
APIs as tool calls
in order to then uh provide these enhanced prompts
to the LLM. So this traditional retail
application is gonna recursively make calls to the LLM.
The LLM maybe requests data,
then makes these tool calls, and then kind of has
this iterative loop. This is something that the developer
is going to write this recursive loop
for until it comes to some type of base
condition that says we are complete and
we are good to then return
some type of response back to the end user.
OK, so
Of course this is now we're talking about agentic
applications and what is the difference between what we
did before and perhaps what is
an agent today and the key difference
here is you'll see at the top there is this
agentic loop
where it repeats as needed. So
what does that look like?
So again we have this prompt, we
have our agent now where it invokes
this model.
Again with that list of tools,
it gets that response back again we went through
this, we execute a tool, we get that
result, and then of course we repeat
as as frequently as needed,
right? And so it is now the agentic framework that
is going to be handling
what, how many times do I actually need to loop. Maybe
I need to do this once or maybe I need to do this 3
times. Um,
so this is something where we're going to think through this
tool execution. So we're going to be continuously
retrieving context
from our different knowledge sources via
these tool calls so that the LLM has
sufficient amount of information or data
or context in order to make a
good decision.
OK, and then of course we then return that final
result. So one thing that we may
want to think through then is we had that
servius API,
uh, we perhaps built it as a
single monolithic agent,
which is OK to start with,
but may, we may also want to start thinking about do we
want to potentially decompose that similar to
what we had done before
when we had monolithic APIs, monolithic,
uh, large services
which again in this audience you probably know all
of the challenges around scaling, around deployment,
around agility.
We can start to apply some of those same principles
as you start to think about agents. It's OK
to start with a monolithic agent,
but maybe as you start to build out the use case, maybe
you want to start to decompose it
again, maybe into agentic microservices.
And here you see we take each of those servius
APIs that we had before,
which again you had done that decomposition previously,
and now we start to wrap them around with
agents.
Now you may be thinking, OK,
kind of makes sense, but why might we want to do
that? So
one reason you may want to think through is
as you build these domain agents you can imagine
you're gonna have lots of uh the business
coming back and saying we want additional capabilities.
Maybe developers realize we can extend
the capabilities and provide better customer
value
with these different domain level agents and so
here we have.
Uh, the inventory agent that
is using that server as inventory API,
but now we start to extend it and say, can we add
additional capability?
Maybe we're gonna add things like find alternative
product recommendations
based on the information that this domain agent
already has.
So this is where you can start to build out additional
capabilities
within a certain scope of, uh,
let's say back office or line of business capabilities.
OK, so
with that, I'm gonna
hand it over.
To Draj
Thank you, Iggy.
So In a nutshell, the,
the principles that Higgy talked about
actually is the
foundational of how you should think about agent and
how it has evolved.
So we started with LLM inferencing,
something like RAG, which provides context.
Then we talked about tool use
where uh you can imperatively call
different tools, and then we talked about agents.
Now my goal here is to show
how this is implemented and how you,
you can see that this evolution going
from like basics
to actually using an agent and developing an agent.
So let's go back to an example that Higgy
talked about.
You have a surveillance application,
you're talking to, let's say, Bedrock models,
and the user is calling
for the same problem that Higgy brought up.
He was charged twice for
The order.
So how an agent or how do you applicate
how your application will handle it today?
Think about
calling an LLM. You have to provide
all the context like
you are an order assistant. These are the tools
that you have at your disposal, and this is
the question of the user problem that the user has.
Now you have to go and solve this.
That's where the LLM figures out
based on the information that you have provided
on the order.
First I have to go and get the order details,
right? And it's the ownership
of the application, the sur application
to go and
somehow fetch the ownership details.
It can go and call an API
invoke a lambda function,
and get that res responses back,
and the main part here is once the responses
received, it has to be fed
back to the LLM as an additional context.
That's how the LLM gets additional context
and
can work on the next steps.
So as the next steps, it can go and say, OK, I have
the information now I have to go and get the invoices,
and once you got the invoice, the results, and
it has to feed that information back to,
uh, the LLM.
And finally,
once all of those things are are figured
out, then it can start the refund process.
Once the refund process is complete,
the final response will be sent to the,
the, the user saying that, OK, the refund was
applied.
So you see that, uh, the agenttic loop
that Haggy was talking about,
without using an agent, we are already talking
about a loop here.
So there is a loop where uh your
application has to talk to LLM.
And LLM has to respond and you have to
feed or
update new context.
Now, I, I heard
about step functions. Like if you can do this in
step functions, right, in a workflow.
In a workflow, if you want to build this, these are
multiple steps.
The most important part is the
choice state here, if you can see
the choice state.
So every time a tool is executed, you
have to figure out in the choice state,
like which
uh tool to use and programmatically
you have to go and execute that tool,
feed that information back
to the model so that loop continues
in a recursive manner,
right? So we
see this as a pattern.
Right, you can do the same thing with lambda functions also
instead of using a step function,
if you want to write that code in a lambda function, you can
do that, uh, but overall we
see this pattern that we have
lambda functions, step functions, or your
application code that is running in,
uh, Fargate or EKS.
It has to follow the same pattern like calling
LLM, calling tools, and it has to go in a loop,
right? So that is the pattern that
we have to build on top of it.
But let's see what are the benefits of this pattern.
If you go with this tool use with lambda
functions or step functions,
you can call the existing APIs.
If you take Amazon Bedrock,
you can call Converse API, invoke API
from those uh services
like lambda functions, and step functions
as native integrations with Bedrock API.
But the important part is the choice
state that I highlighted.
You have to imperatively write the code
to actually figure out which tool to use,
right? So that's
a thing to remember here.
That allows you to
build predefined paths for execution,
so. In, in
most of the cases you'll, you'll have to create a workflow
to create the predefined paths. But what
if you want,
uh, a workflow or a, or a
process or a loop where
things can change dynamically based
on the new context,
right? In this case, if you have to change
anything in the step function, you have to add a new branch
to the choice state
and build,
develop, uh,
test and then deploy and then make the changes,
right? So that's a key thing to remember.
Is there a better way to handle this tight
coupling? So if you think about it, there is a tight coupling,
right? You, whatever branches
you have from Choice State, those are the ones that
will be executed,
and that is how much you are limited with the LLMC
users.
So how can we make it better so that you don't
have the tight coupling,
but
automatically that code execution happens
based on which is the right tool that LLM
talks about,
right? That's where agents
come into the picture.
So the, the drastic difference between
you writing the imperative code.
Compared to what an agent can do,
is the agent has the innate capability
of figuring out which tool to invoke without
you writing the choice date.
So, here is an agent example
where we use strands agent.
Anybody using strands agent yet?
OK, cool.
Strands agent is uh open source
uh strand agent SDK
which we announced a couple of months ago.
Uh, and, uh, that's an easy way to get
started and we'll see how it works.
So now the question is, how should I develop an agent?
Right, we talk, we know how to build lambda functions,
the functions,
but how should I develop an agent?
It's as simple as running another library.
You want to run in a lambda function or
any other compute.
So strands agent is a,
it's a very lightweight open source SDK
to build agents,
and the most important part
that is critical to SRN's agent
is it is model driven
and it relies on the agentic loop capability
that he and I have been talking about.
We'll see how it works.
But how to get started?
With strands agent, you get started very
simple and in a couple of lines. This is
a Python code
where you import strands agent as the library.
You import some tools. There are some
predefined tools that you can import.
You can define an agent like it is
done here, and you can
uh provide a prompt to the agent.
Now, one thing that you don't see here is I have not mentioned
about the LLM.
So Strans agent has this opinionated
way of using
a particular LLM on Bedrock.
If you don't provide that, if you want to experiment, you
can easily start with this,
and it uses a particular model. I think it uses
clots on it 4.5 right now on
Bedrock,
but this is an executable code right now. If
I want to run this as a Python class, it'll
run and give me a response.
Now, how would the order agent look like?
So I showed the
step functions, uh, workflow that was the order agent,
uh sorry, order, orders workflow.
If I want to run the same thing in, uh,
strands agent STK for orders, this is
how it would look like in a single Python class.
First, you import the standards agent from
the SDK. And then if
you see, the most important part here is I
have just Python methods here,
and they are decorated with tools.
And that decorator is from StransAgen,
which means
you can make any of your Python
methods act as tools when
you're working with Stran's agent,
right? And then you create a
voter session,
define which uh region you want to operate
or use, define the model.
In this case, I'm going one step ahead instead of
relying on the default model selection
that stands as, I want to go and use cloud
Haiku 4.5.
And I define the token counts, I defined
the session,
and now I have everything.
I create the agent and if you see line number 111,
I'm providing all the tools which are
just the method names that I have
defined up above,
and then I call the agent.
So,
the drastic difference between the workflow
and this one
is in nowhere in this
code I have
written an if then else logic or a switch
statement. Which means
when
the new context comes or the responses
come from LLM,
the agent's responsibility is to figure
out whether it has to call, get orders detail
or get invoice or start refund
process in whichever order
it has to be invoked,
so there is no imperative code. So we
move from writing imperative code
to actually agent
working in a declarative manner
and getting things done.
So
That's one of the major benefits.
Let's see what else.
Uh, you get in-built error handling.
All the best practices of how agents should
work is available in strands agent
STK, and this is not limited to strands
agent. You can experiment with
any agentic framework, but strands agent,
uh, is something that
I love to work with. It's very lightweight, so
it's, it's very easy to work with,
uh, and then most important part is
model and compute agnostic, which
means. I used Bedrock
model, but strands allows you
to
work with any model provider, not
just Bedrock. It can be
anthropic directly, it can be OpenAI
directly, it can be a model that is running
on Sagemaker as well.
Plus, since it is just an SDK
you can run it in any compute.
It can be a lambda function, it can be
uh Fargate, it can be EKs,
or it can be on your EC2s.
So, that is the important part.
Finally, as I mentioned earlier, the major
comparison
is instead of writing imperative workflows,
which are kind of tightly coupled based on
the use case,
This is much more declarative. So you can define
a new tool by writing a new method
and provide that
tool in the agent uh array, tools
array, and then you're done. And the LLM
and agent will work together to figure out which
tool to invoke in which order.
So now that we have a good understanding
of how a single agent as a unit
of work can be built,
we have to figure out how can you run
those agents at scale
because at the end of the day when you run it in production,
it will not be one
agent running in your machine,
it has to be multiple agents and multiple
tools. So
when you want to run agents and tools at
scale,
this kind of chaos is what you will aim
for or look for,
right? Uh, the reason I say
chaos is because we have
seen the world when it comes from monolithic to microservices,
and we found a way how to build
and operate microservices.
So, there will be agents in
your department, your agents, there'll be
tools that you want to use, which are
very local to you.
There will be agents and tools in your organization.
And there will be agents and tools that
are externally available
at the end of the day you don't want to repeat yourself,
right? If you have tools that are working for you,
your agents should be able to invoke those tools
instead of you creating those uh tools again.
So this is how a production, uh, set
up would look like. Our goal is to
be here
and then run at scale.
So for that we have some standards
that we can rely on
and make agents work with tools and,
uh, other agents, uh.
Seamlessly.
So let's see.
Again, going back to this,
my agent can call a tool
that is inside the department.
Uh, my agent would also need to call a tool
in the organization,
and it can also call, it should be
able to call an external tool. So how do
we make this work?
If we don't use any standards, the
agent and tool integration would look like
this. You have agents.
And if I have to
use
a tool that is supported only
for SQL
or it's a database-specific tool,
then the agent has to write a SQL or has
to support SQL.
And that's the standard of the protocol that has to
be used to integrate with the database.
If the agent has to work with a graphQL
endpoint, then agent has to learn how
what graphQL is
and has to integrate with the graphQL endpoint.
Same with restful endpoints.
So now you can see what is happening. So
agent builders who are building agents,
they are responsible for supporting all those
different protocols,
right? And on the tool side,
whoever is building tools,
they are restricted
to the scope of tool vendors. So if a vendor
is only specifically working on databases.
They have to now think about
their user user bases to grow, their agent,
uh, clients to grow. They have to support
GraphQL or,
uh, Rest Endpoint, whatever. So
it, you can see there is a tight coupling
happening when you think about different protocols
and where agents have to work with
different tools.
Those different, uh, entities, the agent
builders and the tool builders have to
support different ways of communicating, and
that's how they can.
Operate together.
So that's a tight coupling.
And that's where
anthropic.
Came up with MCP.
Has anybody heard about MCP
Model context protocol?
So what it does, it
actually unifies all of those different
standards and says, OK, you don't have to use different
standards when you want to have agent
to tool
uh integration
we'll use MCP as the protocol.
For that you need an MCP client which will be
used by the agent
and an MCP server that has to be hosted by
the tool provider.
So now what happens,
the agent builders will only need to support a single
standard, that is MCP.
And the tool builders or the tool providers
will have to make sure
that whatever capability they have
is exposed as an MCP server
or MCP capability,
right? So how does it look like in
the agency loop
whenever you have agents calling tools,
the agent will work as an MCP client
and the tool providers will have, uh,
will call it as, uh, will be the MCP servers.
So a single
MCP client, a simple MCP client
using Strand's agent would look like this.
Now, if you see here, I have uh imported
strands agent and MCP client
from strands agent
because strands Agent supports MCP client
uh
like natively.
And if you see line number 5,
actually I'm calling an external
or remote MCP server.
Whose job is to go and
uh scrape the web. It's a
web crawler and it should give some
responses back.
And then I get all the tools that the
MCP server has to offer.
I provide that tool to the agent and I ask
a simple question
like what are the top 5 best rated cities
in the USA group by breweries?
And provide the answer in a tabular form.
Anybody from Denver here?
No one?
OK. Because Denver always comes up in
the top,
in the, when it comes to
uh top 5 breweries.
OK, so this is the answer, and I
executed this as just a Python,
ah, class.
And uh
you can see where I've highlighted it executed
the tool that is provided by the remote MCP
server
and it provided the response. It's
scraped through different uh pages
provided the response in a table or format.
So this is a simple example of invoking remote
MCP servers.
Now, if you are building MCP servers,
excuse me,
how would it look like from a MCP server
or a tool provider side?
Uh, the easy way to start building an MCP
server is using fast MCP.
You can import
fast MCP and create a basic
uh fast MCP server. In, in this
case, I'm just creating a math server which
just does the addition of two numbers,
and I've defined these are the tools.
One of the tools is adding two numbers,
and I've decorated that as MCP tool
and I'm just running that MCP server
uh at port 8000.
And when I try to run this up, the
server comes up, it's uh up and ready,
and it should be able to take calls from MCP
clients. OK,
so now we saw from the MCP client side
how should you be building MCP clients, the MCP
server side
where uh the tool providers should be uh building MCP
servers.
So coming back to the same, uh,
uh, running at scale in production,
this is how we ended up with any tool
communication that happens from agent.
Will be over MCP as a protocol,
a standard.
But what if
an agent wants to talk to an agent?
Right? So there can be
a case where agents will try to communicate
with an agent
instead of a tool.
Let's see what happens if we do the same thing
without a standard.
And go from there. So let's go back to the
same use case. Like I was charged twice.
And I have an order agent that is run on strands,
which is an MCP client.
It has its own tool. It talks to its
LLM. It is an agentic loop.
Think of that orange dotted boundary.
It's the,
uh, is the bounded context of orders
agent, right?
Now, in order to get a proper refund
or payments or has to work with the payment
domain. That has the same
setup. Or a similar setup
with an agent
talking to an LLM and a bunch of
tools that are specific to payments.
Now, if I don't use any standard, then
the order agent has to directly talk to the
tools that it is in the
payments domain,
which means
We see a scope creep.
Now the order agent has to understand
what are the tools available in payments domain. So if
you think about it,
this is the same, we are, we are back to square
one when we think about domain-driven design and
building microservices. I think everybody here
will be aware of,
uh, domain-driven design and why should we think about
bounding bounded context.
So there is a scope creep.
You run tools from different domains, so you don't
know. Our order agent will not know
what tools it has to get from payments
domain, what are the authentication and authorization
requirements it has to work through.
There is an ownership leakage because payments
domain has to own its tool
and somehow has to
make sure that it is exposed to other agents
in a way
without,
uh, without other agents directly invoking
the tools, if you think about it.
Last but not the least, if payments agent
is actually
continuously revising its tools or how to
work with tools,
then the order agent has to keep up. Otherwise,
It it might fail.
So how would it look like if we
go one step up and do interagent communication
with MCP because we figured out MCP
is a standard
and an agent can talk to tools,
why not the payment agent work as a
tool for orders agent?
Right? That's doable. It's
better than not having a standard.
Because it relies on MCP as
the protocol.
But the payment agent is used as a
tool. Which means
the audit agent has to discover
what this agent is capable of
or what are the tools that are available
for this agent, and the agent should
somehow be able to figure out, hey, I
have tools A, B, C to work with.
Reach out to me using MCP and I'll have to delegate
all of my MCP calls to my tools.
And then,
if you look at it,
the MCP,
uh, sorry, payments agent must act as an MCP
server for orders agent,
and it has to act as an MCP client for its
own tools,
right? Can we do it better?
That's where Google came up with agent to agent,
which is A2A.
It's a standardized protocol for AI agents.
To discover capabilities of existing
or other agents, exchange
task, and collaborate on complex workflows.
We'll see how it would look like, uh, if you want to
start building with
8W. If you take orders agent
and payments agent,
The first thing that the order agent will ask payment
agent,
uh, if payment agent is the A2A server,
is give me your capabilities, give me your agent
card,
and the agent card will have all the details, the
name, the version, the description of the agent,
and the skills.
The agent will have skills and capabilities,
and that
is kind of abstracting of how this agent
works with its own tools.
From those skills and capabilities,
capabilities and what are the supported mo
modalities,
what are the ways to authenticate and
authorize,
all of those will be present in the model card.
Now the order agent has the model card. It
can figure out how to work with the agent.
It'll create a task for the payments
agent. And then it'll
process the task. In the meantime,
if there is more information required from
the payments agent as an A2A server or
from the order agent as an A2A client,
they'll be able to communicate.
And finally,
the results will be returned back to the order
agent.
OK So now evolving
from just using
MCP
this is how it will look like if you
use A2A.
So it's similar to the concept of
Uh, using choreography for
in between domains and orchestration
inside your domain, so
it has MCP you're using MCP when
the agent has to talk to a tool
and you're using A2A when the
agent has to talk to an agent.
So what are the improvements?
Now your payments agent has,
uh, it's like it is,
it is a specialized agent and it has capabilities
to do everything that it has to do
related to uh payments and
exposes an agent card.
Now, the payment agent doesn't leak the
domain knowledge
because the agent card is taking
care of how
external agents should be interacting with payments agent.
And then
the A2A
as a as a standard as a protocol,
it supports both sync
and async communications
so it can happen where
the payments agent can asynchronously
call or send some responses and
order agent can
provide a web hook or something and it can
get that information back without waiting
on payments agent response.
OK, so this is an overall picture of
how agent to agent will work.
Now can we go one level up? Can we bring
event driven with A2A and MCP?
I'll go back to the same
Uh, example, like
you have.
This is where we left off in the previous slide, like
the agentic loop of orders agent and payments
agent
and A2A for interagent communication
and MCP for communication
inside the domain,
and we have this, uh, request coming
in that I was charged twice for my order.
Can we use event driven architecture? I
believe we can.
And that will allow you to
get more benefits.
What if
that request comes as an API
call and you have an event
producer that accepts that API call
with a standpoint and lambda functions
and then they emit events to even broker
like even Bridge.
Now you have an event going to
orders agent saying that order support
placed. Order
agent can work with payments agent
using A2A
and using MCP for its own
work and then ultimately send an event
back saying that the order support is completed.
Now that event can be captured by the
broker again, and now I have
another event consumer whose work
is to notify the end user,
which can use WebSocket and Lambda and then
ultimately notify the end user.
So, what is the benefit of using this?
We talked about MCP, we talked about A2L
standard, but why EDA?
Why even driven architecture?
So the main benefits is that
it applies to every application that we built
using EDA.
It's loose coupling.
So when you bring loose coupling with intelligent
coordination,
you build something really powerful.
The agent is autonomously working
and it is doing its work
and at the same time you have
the capability of emitting events to
the agent and not wait for the agent to
send responses back,
which means you can scale
really well
without depending on or failing
when the agent fails.
You can get context of event handling.
So MCP provides a standardized way for
agents to access
contextual information
when it comes to databases, APIs, etc.
but an agent receiving a, a
customer inquiry event
can automatically fetch those contexts,
and it can work
independently of other agents.
As I mentioned, you can scale agents,
uh, because
the event that we talked about order,
uh, placed, order support placed.
I just showed you the order agent
working, but what if there are different
other agents that are actually working on that
event? They can start working
on that particular event type
without
touching on order agent or without.
Doing anything with agents, so you can parallel
invoke different agents
when it comes to event-driven architecture.
The other important aspect is the asynchronous
intelligence. So
when something happened in your inside your
system, when
something happens in this, for example, let's
say a support ticket was created
or a payment was asked or
a misplaced order,
when you convert that to an event.
You don't have to invoke an agent
synchronously anymore because now that
event will be actually invoking
or the agent will
come back to life when the event is received.
So it can work asynchronously and do
some lot of intelligent automation for you.
Overall,
you get observability and auditability
because when you use an event broker, you are capturing
all the events that are going to the broker.
And if an agent fails,
you can replay those events and you
can retrigger those agents and make it
work. So that's another capability.
And it's resilient because uh
it's decoupled
and if if the payment agent fails
or if the order agent fails, you'll still
be getting those events.
And you can gracefully degrade by
bringing up another agent or another application
to work on those events.
So overall
these are the
benefits of using all those open standards
with event driven architecture.
If you have to add a new agent,
you don't have to touch anything around what you
have already set up. Like if you, if you
see the, if you,
if I want to add a new agent to this setup
which has to work on the order support placed event,
I don't have to touch anything here.
I'll just add that agent, subscribe to the new
event, and keep on going.
So my.
Like a blast radius will be smaller. I don't
have to test everything.
Cool. So now that we
know how you build
the patterns, even even architectures,
the standards, etc.
the next question is how will I run it on
AWS,
and that's where I have
Higgy
to talk more about how can you deploy agents
and tools and on soveless
compute. Cool,
thank you. Far
we talked about uh tool calls
and these agentic frameworks. This allows
us to use the LLM to reason
through completing these tasks or requests on
behalf of your end users.
Um, we also want to then use
these agentic frameworks and these tool calls to be able to
get additional data context so
that the LLM has the
appropriate amount of information
to adequately process whatever this request
might be,
uh, and then Diraj talked about a bunch of these open standards, ways
that we can.
Uh, make sure that, uh, developers of different
teams are doing this in a uniform way
that makes it simpler for you to then operate
in production. So
let's think through a little bit of how we then do
this using some serverless capabilities
here on AWS. And so we're gonna think
through some patterns here. We're gonna go through
servalus functions with lambda.
We'll do some, uh, servalus containers with,
uh, Fargate, and then of course we'll do a quick,
uh, dive into Agent Corp which went
GA about a month or two ago,
and we'll, we'll look through some of these, uh, deployment
patterns and how you can actually apply this into
your organization.
Before we do that, let's take a quick high level view
of like what does it look like as a developer
as you're building out these capabilities, and the
first thing is that foundation capability
which Draj spent a bunch of time talking through
is you can select whatever agentic
framework you're gonna use. Of course here at AWS
we love strands, but we've also seen some
of our customers choose, uh, alternate
open source frameworks.
And the beauty here is that you can take whatever
framework that you're going to use again I'll just talk about
strands
and you can develop that locally,
do a lot of testing locally,
then you can package it up in whatever
artifact is required for your compute target,
which we're going to talk about momentarily,
so you have that same experience of developing
locally and also deploying
into production.
And then of course when you're then exposing these
whether that's these are in private VPCs
again maybe you have a a requirement that's internal
only I think we were talking about that earlier with some of the
audience
where you have internal only private network
capabilities or maybe you're actually providing
this as a service to your end customers so
necessarily these become public endpoints, right?
And so if you're gonna be doing this with Fargate,
of course you're gonna perhaps use an ALB
and that will become the ingress mechanism
for all requests coming into uh
your agent application.
How you'll be exposing that in this scenario is
just gonna be as a simple HTTP web interface.
Now if you're gonna be doing this with lambda, perhaps
you're gonna have API gateway in front of it.
You're gonna have all of the nice things that API gateway
provides you like an authorizer, WAF integration,
cloud front integration, etc.
And now what you'll use is you're gonna use that lambda
handler that we love
and integrate that with that HTTP interface
for your agentic application.
And then last but not least, we'll cover a little bit of Agent
Core in a moment.
Where that is similar to your
Fargate scenario where you're gonna have your
regular agent application uh with
Agent Corp then we're gonna actually just use imports
and dependencies and then we're gonna actually do a
little bit of annotation which, which again we're gonna
show you momentarily.
The beauty here is that these are all different
options depending on what your organization
uh necessarily requires
uh you know I've talked to some customers where some of them say,
you know what, all of our artifacts are gonna be
container artifacts because we've built out
um our. CI pipelines to
do all of our testing, security scanning, all
of the governance mechanisms based on a container-based
artifact.
Um, if that's the case, then you may actually
make, uh, certain choices about how you're
going to be deploying your artifacts.
Uh, alternatively, if you love lambda and you
love that zip artifact deployment, that could
be one, approach that you're gonna be using, and we're gonna
talk through some of these patterns,
uh, and we'll go through these, um.
One by one, so of course the first one
would be if you're using ECS Fargate
again you have a pipeline based on containers
again you're gonna standardize on ECR or
elastic container, uh, repository.
So your agent application again you're gonna
build that Docker file. You'll then bundle that
as a container image locally,
push that into your ECR image, uh, into
your ECR repository, and then deploy
that into, uh, Fargate
right with the ELB ALB in front of it.
And in this scenario it's just that like
Draj had shared before, this is that fast
API and strands application or
maybe that fast MCP application.
Next, of course then is as this audience is
probably familiar with, as your lambda function
you have both your zip and container deployment artifact,
and this then allows you to give, get that
API gateway to lambda
um deployment architecture.
You can similarly do the same thing
if you're doing MCP servers. So we
spent a bunch of time
talking about agentic frameworks, whether you're using
strands or otherwise.
You could do similar again. Dras showed an example
of being able to do these MCP servers
as well. That same architecture can actually
apply in this serverless paradigm. So
again, whether you're doing it with API gateway and lambda.
Again you have those same artifacts or
you can uh do that into your Far gate.
So the nice thing again here is that uh you
have that local developer experience building out
that framework
again with your local MTP servers. You could
then do things like MTP Inspector to connect
to that MTP server locally
and to do some amount of testing before you do
that deployment.
Um, Similarly, so Draz shared
before about that order, uh, and, and
payments agent scenario.
So if we're gonna actually apply that scenario and
do this now with API gateway and lambda
with all of these serviceless capabilities that we already
love in this scenario, the order agent,
uh, acts as the um.
As the client,
uh, to the payments agent, so you can
imagine having
just a client that connects to the uh
API gateway endpoint for the payments agent,
and that then acts as the A
A to A server.
So across domains across these bounded contexts,
you have these API calls that are going
from, you know, the A to A client in the order agent
lambda function
to the API gateway endpoint in
the payments agent.
And again, as Draja then mentioned, if you want to make
these internal tool calls,
again, these can just be MCP calls
from that each of the respective lambda functions.
So you can imagine the order function. I've written some
of my code,
the code that
Draj was showing before in my lambda function
has that MCP client makes those tool
calls within the order
domain, similarly on the payments
agent side as well.
So the nice thing is that we're going to be applying all
of these servius deployment capabilities and
using those open standards that
Draj had already been talking about.
So uh we talked about all of the
things that we already love oner lists. Um,
another option that you have then is can
we do this at a higher level of abstraction?
Can we have some more fully managed services?
And this is where Agent Core comes into the play, and we'll
do a quick primer here
again. There are gonna be a lot more sessions here at Reinvent where
you can go a lot deeper.
Um, there are kind of a, a suite
of services, uh, that are available to
you to make
the deployment of your agents easier.
The first, of course, is Agent Corp runtime. Agent
Corps run time is really your erless compute
for running your agents,
um, and this allows you to again, again bring
any open source framework
against strands or otherwise.
It can interact with any model again
we of course here prefer you to do it at Bedrock, but
you can then choose any other, uh, provider
for your, uh, for your models.
There's an Asian Core Gateway,
perhaps a little bit analogous to API gateway,
but Asian Core Gateway is built specifically
as a tool aggregator, right, so
this becomes your similar with API gateway
you use API gateway as the front end for all of your
APIs.
Agent Core Gateway becomes the front end for all of your
tools,
um, so it provides very similar, uh, capabilities
around, uh, off and,
uh, a lot of the
that front end capability. It also allows you
to do things as both public tools
or private tools. So a lot of those
same capabilities that you expected out of API gateway
are there available in Asian Corre Gateway.
Um, these are the some of the managed
tools. So again,
Dra showed, uh, like the calculator tool example,
um, common use cases that we see
for people who are building agentic applications
and the type of tools that they need. Again,
Dra showed that browser one with uh the Denver,
uh, pub breweries,
uh, but also there's code interpreter.
Uh, we've seen a lot of customers who say
we're gonna use these LLMs to actually generate
code on behalf on my behalf. However,
given that this is generated code, it is untrusted
code not written by your developers. You don't
necessarily wanna run this in your,
uh, that has exposure to the rest of your
production environment. So we've seen a lot of our customers
say we wanna run untrusted code in
an isolated environment that has no access
to any of my other production data.
Uh, code interpreter is, is a managed capability
that gives you, uh, isolation of
running, uh, untrusted code.
So those, those are just some of the managed tools that are
available to you.
Um, then of course there's agent core identity. One of the
biggest things that Draj and I, as we talk to our
customers around agents and even MCP
is around what are the security implications of
building out these agents.
How do we ensure that if, if my customer
support agent representative is making this request
to my agenttic application.
And then is making downstream tool calls.
How do I ensure that, uh, that
agent is not as uh elevating privileges,
is not getting access to data that he or she
should not have access to.
And so agent core identity is one of those mechanisms
that simplifies the chaining of these
calls
so that, um,
the original principle or the original
user making these calls, uh, that
identity, uh,
or that those permissions are propagated
down even down to the tool calls.
Uh, and then of course we didn't, we're not gonna
cover this in much depth, but as you continue to
build out these agentic applications,
uh, what we're starting to see is, you know,
we talked a bunch about how do we provide context
to the framework, how do we ensure that it has the appropriate
level of data.
Well, there's also that chat interaction um
that you have with your identity application so you can
imagine I'm a customer support representative
you know Higgy just gave this um
this support ticket around, you know, this order
that was uh double charged did
not ship all my items, and I need it
by tomorrow.
You can imagine perhaps I had a prior
uh support session where I was talking about
uh. Issue I had perhaps with payments maybe
there was an issue with my credit card
you can imagine some of that information may be relevant
for this newer
well now it's present, but it could have been a future
uh interaction. So these are interactions
we may want to save and store
where we can do things like short term and long term
memory in order to enhance that personalization
experience uh with these uh different
end user uh interactions.
And of course, as you can imagine with any of
these.
Capabilities we wanna make sure that observability
is tied into this entire stack and so
this is where we standardize on open telemetry
format to ensure that your traces, metrics, and logs
are all shipped in a way that can
be ingested into your, uh, enterprise
observability capabilities.
So this is a quick overview of what Agent Corre
allows you to do. What we're gonna do is we're gonna spend a little bit
more time
on Agent Corp runtime and gateway
aserless options for running your
agents and your MCP servers.
Um, so similar to the deployment patterns
here, fortunately with Agent Corps runtime
you have the same deployment capabilities.
So again in your organization, if you've
built, uh, a lot of your
CI capabilities around deploying to
lambda functions as zip artifacts,
you can leverage those same deployment pipelines
in order to be able to deploy zip artifacts to
Agent Corps runtime.
Again, the same would apply if you're doing this
based on containers.
Similarly, if you're building out, uh, MCP
servers, I know that there are a lot of, uh, folks
that are out there,
uh, either consuming existing public
MCP servers or saying I
have a bunch of internal data,
um, and they're saying I want to be
able to expose this data. Maybe I
wanna build out
an agentic,
uh, data platform that allows,
you know, certain enterprise data to be exposed
to these agents internally in order to be
able to give good internal use cases,
um. This could be something where you build out
an MCP server on top of data. Again,
we want to ensure that security
is implemented in a way that protects that
data so that there is not any
privilege escalation or exposure
of data to entities that should not have
access to that data
and then you could again deploy these MCP servers
into agent core runtime.
Uh, similarly, as we talked about with Agent Core
Gateway, again, Gateway becomes that front
end for all of your tool capabilities.
So again, in your organization you may have lambda
functions already built with some amount
of business logic
that you want to then expose that business logic,
uh. As a tool call
to your agents, well, you don't actually need to
do anything with that lambda function. You don't need to
refactor it to make it a tool. You can
actually put agent core gateway in front of it
and provide it with some additional metadata.
So when you're putting agent core gateway in front of a lambda
function. You provide it with that description
that D Raj had showed before
of the tool description and then uh
that will then get passed uh as part of that,
uh, tool list to the agent.
So now the agent has information about
this particular lambda function and whether
or not it needs to be invoked
similar. If you have open API schemas,
right, so again, lots of folks in this room, I
imagine you're building out your microservices strategy.
You've defined your APIs using open API
schema. You could then import those open
API schemas, and they can then
be exposed as tools via
Agent Core gateway.
OK, So now we go
back to that example where we were doing
this before with API gateway and lambda
where maybe that lambda function was my A
toA client
and maybe uh my API gateway
was exposing that uh that A to A server.
Well, in this scenario now we can replace some of
those serverless capabilities
with Agent core runtime and Agent core
gateway.
So we're trying to make this simpler
and the nice thing here then is with both
the
the A. calls across the agents
but also the the MCP calls
within the agent
um we actually do a lot of the the the
security capabilities with agent core identity.
So I, I spent a lot of time talking to customers
around how do we do to,
uh, you know, with my MCP tool calls
and how do I scope that down to make sure that,
uh, you know, the end user request with
a certain set of scopes can only make these
tool calls
similarly with. With A to A calls
when we're making a call out to a different agent,
we wanna ensure that we're using the right
IDP, the identity provider, and
making sure those OO 2 flows are implemented
throughout that process.
So you know, Agent Core, what we're trying to do
with this service is to make a lot of these,
uh, capabilities more fully managed again
in this audience, you guys love Servius.
We're trying to give you that Servius experience as you're
building out your agents and your MCP
capabilities.
OK, so
We covered a bunch of these practical
deployment patterns. Now we want to think through
again. I had that earlier slide of how do
we start to decompose perhaps that monolithic
agent and go out to these multi-agent
systems. Draj talked about
using these open protocols in order to be able
to have
the different communication patterns, and
then Diraj also talked about some of these EDA patterns.
So let's think through that a little bit more
as we get close to wrapping up. So we have these
decomposed agents,
orders, inventory, payment support agents.
Uh, we've talked about different deployment patterns,
so maybe some of these, maybe one line of business
likes using ALB and Fargate.
Another line of business likes our API gateway lambda,
and maybe another group is like, hey, we're
gonna kind of cut our teeth on Agent
Core. And so again you can make your choices
about where you want to deploy these.
We also talked about uh this uh
orchestration, right, and so those three common
problems. So the first might be
that double charge again perhaps you
you could have just solved this by just doing better unit
integration testing
and uh rooting out the the uh the root
cause in those serverless APIs,
but also you can then uh.
Augment and create an agent that is
able to do some of that root cause analysis on your behalf.
Similarly, uh, for the, uh,
the order that included two items and only shipped
with one, maybe you're gonna actually make
a call out to the orders agent
and go and try to make a determination as
to why it didn't ship.
It may also even talk to the inventory agent.
Maybe it'll go and say actually we,
there was some race condition where the,
the, the front end exposed the fact that we
had one item left, but actually
the reality was that item had already shipped and we
actually were out of inventory. Maybe there was
some type of race condition.
So this type of uh orchestration can
then actually be done all by this orchestrator
agent. So now
again we talked about those challenges of your customer
support agent who wants to get faster
response time, wants to be able to uh resolve
this issue in a quicker way without having to do
a lot of manual work across a lot of different
dashboards.
Well this orchestrator agent can actually do a lot of this
on your behalf and we'll actually simplify
that and get you that better customer experience.
And as D Raj talked about maybe
instead of an interactive customer
support session you could be in a scenario
where maybe this is actually a retail planning
exercise where maybe you're doing.
Uh, quarterly purchasing, uh,
decisioning where you actually wanna make a determination
how much inventory do we need to buy across
different categories.
We just went through Black Friday, but now we're going into
the Christmas shopping period. What type of inventory,
so this could be something now where you build out this
planning agent,
maybe this is actually an async agent going
and working in the background and saying we're gonna go
and collect data from a variety of different data
sources.
And actually we're gonna do this using some of the
async patterns that D Raja talked about before where
we can actually fire off
maybe we're gonna go and do research in our inventory database
we're gonna do some analysis on what
is the history of order pattern over the last 36
months, over the last 48 months,
um, and then we're gonna actually collate that with,
uh, maybe different, uh, orders
information and so we can start to get and
build out some of these reports
that maybe your inventory planning or your
retail planning team can then leverage.
The other benefit here, uh, again, as D Raja
talked about then is that you can
imagine maybe some of these agents have different scaling
requirements.
Maybe the inventory agent is one that
is far busier and maybe that actually needs
to scale out, uh, far more rapidly,
whereas maybe the support agent.
Maybe you've actually built your system so well
that you're the number of support requests
is actually reducing and so maybe that's something
that doesn't need to scale
as rapidly and so this allows you to then
uh similar with the microservices world, scale your
resources based on wherever the requirements may be.
OK, so let's talk, uh, a
little bit about pros and cons of some of these different architectural
patterns that we've been talking through here. So if
we start with that single agent architecture,
um, again, similar with monoliths, it's just
easier to develop, uh, it's easier to
debug. You get clearer reasoning traces,
um, and possibly, I, I
say possibly, uh, fewer compute
resources again, the idea being that,
um, because I don't need to make these
network calls, I don't need to do a lot of waiting, etc.
These might be certain benefits. It just is simpler
to be able to build out
these capabilities.
Um, however, for those that are already experimenting,
you're probably aware when you're interacting with LLMs
there is this notion of a context window
that data that we've been collecting
and enhancing that prompt with
is a finite amount of data that we can
provide to these LLMs. So you may
have heard of there, there are some models at this point that
can handle a million. Token, uh,
context windows
and so
you could put in theory exceed that
context window and uh you
would then have to do some work around compressing
whatever information that you wanna provide to that context.
The other challenge is if you put too much context
that is not relevant to that particular request,
you may be in a scenario where it takes longer
for the LLM to respond and it's actually more
expensive than it need be.
And so this is where you may want to start thinking about do
we want to decompose into these finer grained
uh smaller agents that
have, uh, maybe they're gonna be faster
and actually perhaps cheaper
to run with these models.
So there are a couple of multi-agent patterns that we're seeing
some of our customers build out. So the first is
this, this serialized pipeline.
So this could be something like we're doing a
content generation, right? So you can imagine in
content generation you're gonna do some amount of
research.
You're gonna then maybe build out a draft,
and then you're gonna maybe build out a final,
um,
maybe a final production copy, and
then maybe you're gonna do some, uh, feedback loops,
um, you can imagine this is a scenario
where, uh.
This is just simple to model. I, I realize
I'm running out of time here, so I'm gonna speed up along,
um, but there are downsides similar to Christmas lights.
If there is a problem at one point in
the stage, you can actually end up bottlenecking
there. The next is the orchestrator
pattern which uh we've already talked about kind of
at length here. This allows you to do decomposition,
allows you to actually orchestrate some of these patterns,
um, uh, but again there is some communication
overhead as we had just mentioned.
And then the last pattern here is around
a swarm architecture, right? And so the idea here
is you may have a scenario where you wanna do
actually a broad research. You don't have a
finite path to that end result
where you maybe actually wanna send out a large
number of agents or a number of agents to go
and do research in parallel. It's
kind of like the scatter gather pattern where you're gonna go
out and do research. You're gonna bring that back and try to synthesize
what a number of these uh agents have done.
The challenge here though is that uh in
this type of swarm architecture it is a lot more
difficult to reason about some of the behavior
uh and it is somewhat harder so again
make sure that your
uh your use case aligns to whichever pattern
makes the most sense
again I realize I'm coming up on time. I'll just skip
to the last one
we talked a little bit about security, so this is one
where you wanna build out your agents in a way
that propagates uh security context
appropriately. You also want to make sure that you
are, uh.
Have steps along the way where
uh as an end user comes into the agent,
the agent comes into the MCP server and the MCP
server makes the the downstream API calls
you wanna make sure that those are all separate
set of tokens. You don't wanna use the same token
throughout.
And of course with governance
uh
you wanna make sure that you are using the same
type of governance policies mechanisms
that you're deploying into production
um
that you've already been using all right so just a couple
of takeaways as we try to wrap up here,
um, so a lot of the, the things that you've
already been doing with serverless APIs in
production you can actually continue to apply
those as you're building out, uh, agents into
production as well.
Um, you wanna use agents in a way that
really bridges data and gleans insight,
uh, out of that information. Again, you don't wanna use this
kind of as this low level shim across your data.
Uh, you wanna use this as higher order insight gathering
and servius again can be a way to accelerate,
uh, your path to production.
And of course, uh, as we talked about a lot of these patterns
that allow you to scale your agents,
um, as you build out your particular use
cases again there are,
there are a number of, um,
key considerations. I think we're out of time at this
point, but, uh, certainly just make sure
that you're documenting along the way,
uh, build and be scrappy,
uh, and then again document and provide feedback
so that your internal platform teams, your internal
developer teams are able to learn from
the things that you are learning within your organization.
We do have a number of resources
again you can take a quick picture of that one and find
that afterwards.
Um, there are a number of other sessions
that we wanna encourage you to to participate
in and so these are some of the other ones that we
recommend you go and check out.
And of course there are other servalless resources.
This deck will be provided afterwards as well, so
I, I recognize there are a bunch of people trying to take pictures,
uh, and again Draj and I do wanna thank you.
You can find our socials here so you can connect with us
afterwards. Thank you everyone,
and we, uh, thank you.
Please do fill out the survey. We appreciate it.